on Saturday left us around the nation
took to the streets to sound off about
their new religion science no not
testable hypotheses and well-constructed
experiments science you know like gay
rights and abortion and global
redistribution ISM and dying polar bears
and stuff leading the charge was eminent
scientific revolutionary Bill Nye the
Science Guy a mechanical engineering
degree holder who got famous as a
children's television presenter and I
was a keynote er at the March for
science where he said quote we are
marching today to remind people
everywhere our lawmakers especially of
the significance of science for our
health and prosperity
what sort of science was nice standing
up to defend budget increases for the
EPA and the National Institutes of
Health of course he explained how all of
this was scientific and not political he
said somewhere along the way there has
developed this idea that if you believe
something hard enough it's as true as
things discovered through the process of
science and I will say that's
objectively wrong belief isn't science
this is a good point unfortunately
neither then followed up his widely
praised appearance at the March for
science by unleashing a video that
destroyed the internet from his new show
Bill Nye saves the world he trotted out
crazy ex-girlfriend actress Rachel bloom
to sing a very special song as her nice
words she warbled and here's the
dramatic read my vagina has its own
voice not vocal chords a metaphorical
voice sometimes I do a voice for my
vagina because my sex junk is so much
more than either or-or-or power bottom
or power top versatile love may have
some but stuff it's evolution ain't
nothing new there's nothing taboo about
a sex stew this is real this happened if
they're alive I'll date them chanting or
Jenna Tatum I'm down for anything don't
box in my box science
if these all seems rather unscientific
to you if you wonder why I talked to him
for China with obvious self control
problems is being trotted out by the
self-proclaimed science guy you're not
alone you're rational we might even be
using some scientific thinking but this
is demonstrative of the left's take on
science science is actually just the
name for anything left likes worried
about the humanity of an unborn child
concerned that fetuses have their own
blood types in their own DNA
stop it you're quoting science not
science wondering how it is that a
genetic male is actually a woman you're
worrying about science not science this
is a dirty little secret of the left
sudden embrace of science it's not
science that they support but religion
they support that which they believe but
cannot proven do not care about proving
Bill Nye isn't interested in a
scientific debate about global warming
how much is occurring the measurement
techniques had issued the sensitivity of
the climate to carbon emissions the
range of factors that affect the climate
he wants you to accept his version of
the truth not just that global warming
is happening but that massive government
intervention is necessary in order to
avert imminent global catastrophe such
government solutions aren't verifiably
scientific they're speculative but that
speculation has costs particularly to
the most impoverished people on the
planet who benefit disproportionately
from cheap carbon-based fuels even if
you accept the UN Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change estimate that
sea levels will rise by 2 feet over the
course of the rest of the century and
the temperature will rise about 7
degrees Fahrenheit there is reason to
question as Oran Cass points out whether
or not massive government intervention
is necessary or even justifiable but the
left refuses to acknowledge such
questions it makes you a denier to
disagree with the left's conclusions
just as it makes you a cruel person to
wonder whether gun control will actually
lower the American murder rate science
in other words is just a baton for the
left a decade ago the left declared
President Bush anti science for his
restrictions on the use of new federally
funded fetal stem cell lines they
claimed that Bush hated science that
fetal stem cells were the wave of the
future that Bush was a moral Ayatollah
in the words of Senator Tom Harkin
Democrats ran on the promise that if
Bush were thrown out of office in 2004
they'd make Christopher Reeve walk again
using fetal stem cells but it turned out
fetal stem cells were unnecessary to
scientific research scientists came up
with an embryo free process to produce
genetically matched stem cells as
Charles Krauthammer no religious
fundamentalist and the guy who by the
way is paralyzed wrote at the time
rarely has the president so vilified for
a moral stance been so thoroughly
vindicated why precisely because he took
a moral stance in other words bush
didn't rely on science to give him his
values nor should he have science is not
capable of making value-laden decisions
there are plenty of ob/gyns who know
better than the most pro-life
conservative just how complex life is in
the womb
yet they will perform abortions science
has not dictated their behavior the
Nazis were famously Pro science
declaring that science itself mandated
the killing of the unfit for the
strengthening of the race their racism
was supposedly scientific that's why the
march for science is such foolishness
if the March were simply focused on
advocacy for increased EPA funding that
would be political not scientific
if the marchers were demanding more
funding for the NIH - that's who would
be political but with a stronger
scientific component but the March for
science was actually a march for science
the leftist religion and that leftist
religion isn't
said in science in the slightest it's
simplistic and simple-minded virtue
signalling i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show okay i'm much more to
say about science and will also give you
the update on what's going on with hand
culture at berkeley we'll give you the
update on the health care negotiations a
lot going on in the news but first i
want to say thank you to our sponsor is
over at blinds.com so if you're one of
these people who has a set of beat up
lines left you by the person who
bequeathed you your apartment or your
house and you want to replace those
blinds with something really really nice
blindness calm is the place to go they
are cheaper they are better they make it
really easy for you so if you're not
sure what you want you go to blinds calm
you get a free online design
consultation you send them pictures of
your house they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme in
your furniture and specific rooms
they'll even send you free samples to
make sure that everything you see online
looks just like it does in real life and
if you miss measure or pick the wrong
color then blinds.com will remake your
blinds for free so if it's your screw up
they will still remake your blinds for
free right now if you go to blinds calm
promo code Ben you get 20% off
everything and they have blinds that are
really top-notch we're not talking about
these cheap plastic blinds that you get
at the local A&P we're talking about
blinds that you know are high quality
we're talking wood we're talking and
they have tons of options I've looked at
them I've used them myself blindness
calm you get 20% off everything when you
use that promo code Ben they faux wood
blinds and cellular shades and roller
shades and more again blinds calm promo
code Ben for 20% off everything blinds
calm promo code Ben can't recommend them
highly enough they are a terrific
company and they do terrific work again
there's no risk if you screw it up you
don't like what you got you can always
send it back so that is the the
wonderful thing about blinds I come
they'll replace it if you screw up the
measurements and they'll help you
through the process all the way through
ok so the democrats continue to harp
about science and their new favorite
science people are obviously they love
Caitlyn Jenner because Caitlyn Jenner's
aunt Lin Chen arisen is an emissary for
science which is silly but the other
person who is the emissary for science
is Bill Nye the Science Guy which just
demonstrates in the left which claims
that it's just terrible we have a
celebrity president the person that they
are trotting out is their lead
spokesperson for science is a guy with a
mechanical engineering degree from
Cornell right in like 1979
that guy is the scientist who they think
is the expert on all things scientific
and that means that Bill Nye is pushing
his version of science what is his
version of science look like well again
he has this idiotic show on Netflix
called Bill Nye saves the world and as I
said yesterday spoiler alert he doesn't
here is a segment from that horrible
show in which he says that
three-year-olds should be able to choose
their own gender by three or four most
kids identify with a gender and it
doesn't always match the sex they were
assigned at birth and a person's gender
identity may change over their lifetime
and culture is getting us new ways to
express all of this how you dress act
talk how you present yourself to the
world it should be up to you sure this
might make things confusing for those
who insist everyone pick an M or an F
people we have to listen to the science
and the science says we're all on a
spectrum
okay science does not say you're on a
spectrum of sex when they say gender see
this is what the Left likes to do and
it's really really stupid okay the left
says that gender is a social construct
and what they mean by that is femininity
and masculinity our social construct
here is the truth about that there are
certain aspects of masculinity that are
certainly not a social construct higher
levels of testosterone average higher
levels of violence by males than females
that is not a social construct that is a
biological reality ok so that is not an
aspect of gender that's more an aspect
of sex the left likes to conflate Sendra
sexes and genders they separate these
two things they say sex is your biology
and then they say the gender is a social
construct that says you need to be
masculine or you need to be feminine now
not a lot of people that I know actually
care whether you act masculine or
whether you act feminine per se but
that's not choosing a gender ok this
just whether you ask Matt act masculine
or feminine then what the left does is
they say your masculinity or femininity
we can now read back into your sex so in
other words if you are a feminine man
right if you're a man who is
biologically male and you act feminine
maybe you're a woman okay this is stupid
and a scientific there's no evidence for
it at all it is also evil to suggest
that a three-year-old and knows that
they're going to choose a gender that is
opposite of the one that they have a
three year olds don't know anything I
know because I have a three-year-old
three-year-olds do not know anything it
is your job as an adult to teach them
about things that are complex and make
the complex simple in ways that they can
understand
if when they hit 15 they're still having
problems then we can have a conversation
about this but this idea that
three-year-olds are capable of choosing
their gender is asinine anyone who has a
three-year-old will tell you this and it
is cruel to a three-year-old to say to
the three-year-old that you're willing
to be allowed to define your own essence
of the world and you're going to be
allowed to override your own biology a
three-year-old is not capable of doing
that and there is no science to support
this what he has is the anecdotal
evidence saying that people who are 20
say when I was 3 I felt like a girl in a
boy's body and that is not scientific
evidence that there is a some brain test
we can run that determines you are
actually a girl in a boy's body there's
no scientific evidence to that effect
the idea that he is saying this is
purely anti scientific but again it's a
political agenda masquerading a science
I'm old enough to remember when Bill Nye
was on to my television explaining that
sex was a function of chromosomes and
that was actual science and now he's
saying sex is a function of what's ever
in your head and it can change over time
your gender can change over time and
again the left likes to play this this
word game where they say well we don't
mean your sex can change over time we
mean your gender can change over time
and they say what do you mean by that
and they say what means you can be a
woman okay now you're talking about sex
again that's not the same thing if
you're going to separate out the two
terms you have to be very specific and
how you use gender if you mean that
there can be a person who changes their
behavior over time bucking particular
stereotypes about feminine and masculine
that I'm sure is true because people do
it every day
what is not true is that you can change
your sex and left conflate the two after
separating them out they like to pretend
that everything that is feminine is not
linked to sex and then they pretend that
if you are masculine as a girl that
means that you must be actually secretly
a man or you can choose to be a man
which is just a scientifically stupid
three-year-olds should not choose their
own gender parents who do this to their
child are doing something evil to their
children your goal in life is not to
confuse your children your goal in life
is to simplify things for your children
again three-year-olds are not capable of
making these types of decision and trend
damming a child to a lifetime of
suffering is just cruel
the studies show that eight in tenth
kids who at any point suffer from any
sort of gender identity issues grow out
of that by the time they hit their
teenage years and what what he is saying
is that we should tell all kids 100 out
of 100 kids we should tell them all they
can pick their sex so now you're selling
a bunch of three-year-olds more about
nature dumb that they can pick their sex
okay they can't and it is a lie and then
beyond that lie you're now confusing 103
year old let's take it statistically
let's you can pretend that Bill Nye was
right okay let's pretend that is
biologically decided that you're a boy
in a girl's body or some such nonsense
which is just not true and again there's
no scientific evidence to suggest that
you're a boy in a girl's body in fact
even the people who say the brain scans
show differences between transgender
people and people who are not
transgender
even though say that it is a transgender
brain but it does not mean that you have
a woman's brain in a man's body it just
means that you have differences from the
traditional male brain that even that is
really scanty evidence but that's the
furthest the good scientists will go and
to say anything different is just not
scientific but let's take this
statistically and assume that the left
is even correct okay so the transgender
suicide rate over the course of a
lifetime is forty percent forty percent
less than one person per 100 is going to
be transgender in the United States it's
just it's very very rare okay and it's
getting more common now because it's
become kind of trendy and because if
you're a teenager and you want attention
then you can do it or if you have doubts
then we have decided that we're going to
promulgate those doubts into reality
so even if you're not just trying to do
it for some nefarious reason if you have
doubts we're now trying to reinforce
those doubts of society but let's use
the numbers on hand so like say one out
of a hundred kids is has gender identity
disorder or gender dysphoria okay now
you're talking about that kid having a
forty percent lifetime suicide rate
there's no evidence that that is
mitigated in any significant way by
society's acceptance of transgenderism
now you're saying that let's say that
they're 100 kids who are told they can
pick their gender and ten of those kids
are now confused right not even 110 of
those kids are now confused and let's
say men normally according to those
statistics virtually all of them would
grow out of this confusion virtually all
of them will grow out of this confusion
but now you're reinforcing the
confusions now let's say those ten all
say I'm the other sex
so now you've taken a situation in which
one kid had a transgender identity issue
and has a forty percent lifetime suicide
rate and you're now extending that to
ten kids and let's even say that this
new process lowers that one kids rate of
suicide attempt let's say that it with
the suicidality let's say that it lowers
it from forty percent to twenty percent
let's say it halves it okay now if
you've increased the number of people
who are engaging in this particular in
this particular problem by three if you
have confused three more
kids then you now have four kids unless
I can take the ten let's say you know
four out of 100 of a 20% suicide rate as
opposed to one out of 100 who has a 40%
suicide rate
you've not improved things you've made
things worse in terms of people who are
suicidal for example okay this is just
to take the statistical case but again
there is no moral case for confusing
your child sex differences are important
reinforcing sex differences is important
because if you don't want your child to
suffer from tremendous cognitive
dissonance then the kid at least has to
know about the standard and then later
they can choose whether or not they want
to engage in the standard but the fact
is the standard is the standard and the
standard is not entirely constructed by
society it wasn't like every society in
the world came up with the idea that men
were going to be soldiers and women are
going to be mothers okay there's a lot
more to that than just society's
deciding things so this is all stupidity
but again it's not science it is
politics and Bill mind did another one
of these thing again this show is just
so awful I don't know how Netflix even
greenlit it except they're a bunch of
leftist Bill Nighy ran a segment about
sexuality of ice cream yes really
of course enlightened and
forward-thinking but not everyone sees
it this way but there are lots of
flavors too sexuality like why are we
here vanilla deal oh this again come on
jobs settle everybody settle now I've
spoken to some of you about my theories
on the nature of being ice cream which
have no basis in time it's the science
of feeling and as vanilla I feel that I
am the most natural of the ice cream and
therefore the rest of you should just go
ahead and also be vanilla oh it's the
one true flavor second obviously the
implication is here they're a bunch of
religious fanatics who want everybody to
be straight and if they're not straight
then then we're going to force them to
be straight okay a couple of things that
are worth noting here
the reality is that biologically
speaking it is more conducive to
evolution and the end the species for
people to be heterosexual this does not
mean that everybody has to be
heterosexual we should use the
government to force people god forbid to
engage in sexual activity of some sort
but this idea that it is that that there
that all sexuality all sexual behaviors
created equal in terms of its benefit to
the species is just not true that's just
not true that is a feelings driven
position but again they're going to push
this idea again I'm waiting to hear who
out there is saying that everybody needs
to be straight I don't think that every
like there not a lot of people out there
saying everybody needs to be straight
there are people who are religious I'm a
religious person I may think that it is
sinful for people to engage in
particular types of sexual congress but
that's my prerogative you may think I'm
wrong congratulations it's a free
country invaded strawberry delicious all
cards but no one can make you stop being
strawberry strawberry your strawberry
holy salted caramel I just think if you
want to get right with the big ice cream
in the sky change your flavor by wishing
to be vanilla what is the big ice cream
in the sky is chocolate blasphemy
everyone should pretend to be vanilla
until they no longer have the urge not
to be vanilla I did not urge to be
pistachio I am pistachio hey make
chocolate chip sorry I'm late I was busy
being too awesome things at mommy
oh not cool pick a lane but stain then I
was trying to convert us all again
that's not no offense math come on come
on somebody wants just one flavor of ice
cream did I do
haven't you ever wanted to be in the
Neapolitan I I can't I can't come on
it's natural all natural cocoa and
strawberry fresh from the field it's so
creamy and delicious mmm
big ice cream in the sky help me hi it's
good I'd like a chest the bowl okay so
in other words everything is natural
except for heterosexuality got it
that is the the bottom line is that all
religious people are secretly repressed
people who want to have orgies with
members of the same sex bisexuals
transgender people and if they could
just taste all the other flavors of the
rainbow everything would be wonderful I
love this idea that biology does not
dictate heterosexuality but it dictates
that you are supposed to have sex with
everything that moves okay there is no
scientific basis for anything that is in
this video this idea I guess the idea is
that everybody's sexuality is on the
spectrum first of all here's what the
science actually says about this what it
says the female sexuality is more
malleable based on environment and
genetics male sexuality is a lot more
binary yeah this is what the is what
every study ever done on sexuality is
said men tend to be either very gay or
very straight and women tend to there is
a spectrum of sexuality for women
whatever the bottom line is that when
they say that that basically straight
people are secretly gay but you can't
say that it's a gay person is secretly
straight or has tendencies in that
direction amazing how all this works but
again it's just it's propaganda it's not
science and it's not even good right I
mean it ends with ice cream having sex
with each other or something I'm just
confused ice cream doesn't have just on
a scientific basis folks ice cream does
not have genitalia okay and if it does
don't eat it because that's not ice
cream okay so before we move on I want
to say thank you to our sponsor is over
at Mack Weldon calm so if you are
looking for the best underwear you're
looking for the best sweatshirts you're
looking for the best comfortable wear
Mac Weldon is better than whatever you
are currently wearing Mac Weldon common
spelled M ACK Weldon wel do n comm and
you get 20% off when use promo code
Shapiro it's sha Piro they have a line
of silver underwear and shirts that are
naturally antimicrobial so they get rid
of the stench they are really really
comfortable as I said I have a bunch of
math Weldon underwear and I threw out
all the other underwear that I own
because these are super super
comfortable and they also hold up really
well in the wash they're not going to
fall apart after after 7:00 where's Mac
Weldon com super comfortable they also
it's also really good-looking clothes
you can go
their site check it out socks shirts
undershirts hoodie sweatpants more than
you'll ever wear but it's stuff that you
can wear out because it's so
good-looking
in many cases Matt Weldon comm use that
promo collection pair you get 20% off
your first order at math Weldon comm for
daily wear okay meanwhile in the non
bill my news and I know we just spent a
lot of time on Bill Nye but that's
because I think that this is used as
propaganda by the left again the idea
there's also something else here that I
think it's worth noting on that idiotic
ice cream video the conflation of
biology with morality is really stupid
the idea that we're all biologically
built to have sex with everything and
therefore it's good and anybody who says
that it's bad is wrong
okay biology does not make things right
there are a lot of things that are
biological that are not right there are
people who have to we all have a
tendency I have a tendency to be
promiscuous because I am a male I have a
biological drive to have sex with many
women I'm extraordinarily monogamous
because I have a religious belief and a
moral belief that it would be cruel to
my wife to cheat on her and would be
really bad to cheat on my wife it is
immoral to do that okay we have that a
society that's a good thing that we have
that as a society even if morality is is
bucking biology into quote the old movie
the African Queen with Katharine Hepburn
and Humphrey Bogart nature is what was
nature nature is in many ways what we
were put here to rise above the idea
that nature is supposed to dictate your
behavior is really pure I'll and stupid
but it is also the basis of the left
political viewpoint okay
in other news Donald Trump is still
pushing for the the wall to be built but
it is not happening it appears that he
is now caving on the wall with regard to
the budget the Republicans are also
putting together a health care plan but
if you want to hear about all of that
you will have to go over to Daley wire
calm right now and subscribe $8 a month
will get you a subscription to daily
wire calm you can see the rest of the
show live again part of the mailbag
which we'll be doing tomorrow tomorrow
is already Thursday right I mean this
week is moving quickly so we will be
doing the mailbag tomorrow and if you
want to come an annual subscriber you
get a free copy of the Arroyo fictional
film set on the southern border about
why we need that Trump wall and why it's
stupid the Republicans aren't going to
build that Trump wall daily wired.com to
get that subscription or if you just
want to listen later go over to iTunes
or SoundCloud check us out over there
become a subscriber in iTunes we always
appreciate you leaving a review this is
the largest conservative podcast in the
United States
[Music]
you